hey guys super quick tutorial on how to
do barrel man see this is super powered
move so you want to kind of do this
bearing Li but I'm gonna show you how to
do it just in case you have like one
tricky boss so what you want to do is
you want to get one character with
telekinesis and put them in battle or
put them to an NPC you want to kill so
let's just use camp boss Grif put him in
position the other character is usually
overweight with all the items that you
want to throw and you will put all the
items in one container and you want the
outside container to have no vitality
because when every time we throw it it's
gonna be damaged so if the outside
container has no vitality can use it
over and over again and a quick way to
check that is just the toggling info and
it does nothing has no HP anyway so you
change for this to the character with
telekinesis that is gonna barrel mance
and then so this guy all he has to do is
drop the item and then you want to click
move to and then just move it to the
opposite side now that one didn't get
them that time every so often you're
gonna get him either a miss but this
only cost one ATP so you do it like
twice there we go he's dead and that did
a ton of damage it maybe didn't show it
I don't know but there you go